Two boys are now on a journey in search of a phantom kilo and rust that is said to love all the rust in Japan with a joker because of the rust that
erodes the waiting town.  The
one who seems to
die if you let go  The child of the branch
tree Pay the wasabi
[Music]
Living alone
Please take me too
What boy should save his loved one
When a new adventure begins The city of Japan
has been covered with rust Next
here
[Music]
n
Ampa I'm moving out of my new house. You
can live a kid who grew up in the city.
President Abe I'm worried about rain.
I think it's a wickedness to
help
you,
but I think too much about Burger,
yeah yeah yeah
rar
ah ah
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
I believe in you
Error
Wasabi tired to the hearts of people
Upy Fiscar
Miro
Rusty Boyster
[Music]